est-ce qu'on n'est pas bien là est-ce
qu'on n'est pas bien comment est ce que
vous allez vous est-ce que d'aller la
pêche avant de tendre à ca m'a demandé
de vous présenter deux chromebook 2
chromebook plutôt à usage professionnel
on a donc deux produits super
intéressant le premier c'est celui là
c'est le chromebook spinks à 112 et on a
le acer le chromebook spin 513 deux
modèles alors qu'est ce qui se cache
derrière ces références à bien il se
cache des choses très intéressantes des
produits qui sont là pour les
professionnels nous ont même envoyé des
petits gâteaux à l'homme sa faune très
bon je vous parle beaucoup de produits
très grand public lassé des premiers
plus destiné aux professionnels
si on est grand public on peut vouloir
aller dessus parce que ces deux premiers
qui sont vraiment vraiment différent qui
ont chacun à leur adn
si vous vous posez la question d'acheter
un chromebook dans l'univers de la serre
et bien la regarder on va y répondre on
va regarder ça on va regarder ce qu'ils
peuvent faire les différentes ça tout ça
me semble donc ça c'est plutôt bien
maintenue pour le gâteau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces documents d'une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec acer for
business le chromebook
on en a déjà parlé mais est ce que vous
connaissez prom enterprise 34 ans pour
est pourquoi des solutions sécurisées
basées sur le cloud qui va ni répondre
aux enjeux actuels pour le travail et
brident ça pour les entreprises et qui
servira à simplifier la gestion du parc
informatique
alors ça c'est bien mais qui est assez
fort disney ça alors c'est acer c'est
assez rare pour le business et qui a
certes business marco au concours un
truc assez fascinant en fait à sa forme
business va accompagner les boîtes qui
veulent faire le choix de chrome
enterprise pour info et si vous ne savez
pas quels sont les avantages de la
licence chrome enterprises et bien pour
une entreprise qui souhaite intégrer et
gérer un parc chromebook
il est nécessaire pour eux d'associer
une essence chrome enterprises of great
un chromebook
ou alors il faut acheter directement un
chromebook enterprise qui a déjà une
licence ce qui est notamment le cas ici
du chromebook spin 513 et vous aide à
trouver un bon produit acer pour vos
équipes pour les entreprises et vous
accompagne sur le service après vente en
france et aujourd'hui nous avons une vie
très différents mais très con là vous
présenter alors on y va voici le acer
chromebooks pin 500 nous allons celui là
il a une particularité qui est vachement
bien c'est qu'en fait en plus d'avoir un
côté l espèce de des faits textures et
qui vachement sympa d'avoir petit logo
cromitie et d'être tout mignon fait qui
est vachement bien que celui-là c'est
qu'il a une certification militaire
ce qui fait que c'est une machine qui
est hyper hyper hyper résistante
il est une norme militaire qui lui
permet de supporter un poids jusqu'à 60
kg et de survivre à une chute de 1,2 m
le but c'est pas de le jeter mais si
comme il survivra et en plus de ça le
clavier un système de drainage permet
d'évacuer 300 30 millilitres de liquide
et si vous avez un verre corning gorilla
glass antimicrobiens et vous avez à
l'intérieur du revêtement du clavier et
de la surface environnantes des agents
antimicrobiens et you d'argent conforme
aux normes
bpr le père il présente donc un taux de
réduction microbes y est élevé contre un
large éventail de bactéries conforme à
des protocoles de test donc ça c'est
cool ici on a un écran hd tactile à dix
points de contact 12 pouces c'est une
dalle ip est complètement tactile très
pratique
et toc est vraiment intéressant ici
c'est le format vous avez un format 3/2
et non pas un format 16 9ème qui vous
permet de gagner 10 8% en plus
d'affichage pour votre écran pour avoir
accès à davantage d'informations ce qui
évite de venir scrollé ce qui paraît
relativement pratique et on retrouve un
écran avec un verre corning gorilla
glass
vous pouvez bien l'utiliser trois
manières différentes première manière
ces modes portable l'ordinateur un peu
classique vous connaissez l'histoire le
mode tablette vous
prenez vous retourner et vous l'utiliser
comme une petite tablette ça aussi c'est
super bien très facile pour venir
naviguer faire tout ce qu'on a à faire
dessus
le mode écran vous le prenez clavier
poser en bas et vous l'utiliser comme ça
plutôt bien et puis vous avez le mode
tente vous le retourner comme ça vous le
poser sur une table pour me regarder du
contenu pour venir travailler et
collaborer de cette manière là le mode
tenté aussi super pratique lui c'est
vraiment un chromebook tout terrain
quelle que soit la zone la surface
l'endroit où vous allez venir collaborer
eh bien il va s'adapter et ça c'est
vraiment hyper pratique côté
performances on va retrouver un
processeur intel à basse consommation
c'est un pentium silver n 50 mille trois
cent quatre coeurs on a eu dix gadrat on
lp ddr4 et on apprendre de giga de
stockage en emc côté connectique on va
retrouver de l'usbc une prise usb à un
lecteur carte microsd une prise jack et
de l'autre côté on a également de l'usb
à de l'usbc et vous avez même un petit
bouton aussi pour venir monter le volume
élevé c'est plutôt sympa le truc est
assez sympa ici c'est que vous avez deux
webcams vous avez une 1ère web calquer
planque et là c'est une webcam de 8
mégapixels et vous en avait une deuxième
qui est planqué juste en bas et qui
servira lorsque vous allez venir changer
la disposition de votre ordinateur
forcément en fonction de la disposition
l'ordinateur je vais pas l'utiliser de
la même manière puis donc ici une fois
de plus de la flexibilité et que ce soit
sur cette machine ou bien sur l'autre
j'ai chrome os qui est extrêmement
facile à venir utiliser qui est très
très intuitif et surtout j'ai bénéficié
ici duplaix store avec un catalogue
énorme avec pleins d'applications qui
sont complètement sécurisée parce
qu'elles ont été testés avant d'être
inséré ici dans le plein sens donc là on
est vraiment tranquille et en plus ici
et c'est vraiment le gros point fort du
chromebook donc ici un ordinateur qui
permettra à obtenir une bonne journée de
travail sans problème et maintenant on
va passer au spin 513 on est toujours
ici sur un chromebook monde y raconter
une histoire un peu différente
on a ici un écran full hd de 13,3 pouces
et du 16/9 c'est une dalle épaisse avec
un verre corning gorilla glass
côté connectique on va retrouver de
l'usbc de l'usb à une prise jack et ici
c'est en option et je peux faire une
carte sim 4g pour me connecter partout
de façon nomade et ça s'est super bien
et donne côté jane usb c'est un bouton
pour vient d'allumer et si également de
petits boutons pour le lieu ici je suis
sur un châssis en aluminium suis sûr
poids plume de 1,2 kg c'est extrêmement
compact ah non ça c'est vraiment un
ordinateur qu'on va glisser très
facilement dans une sacoche
on va retrouver les mêmes quatre modes
qu'on avait tout à l'heure le mode
ordinateur
le mode tablette le mode écran on vient
de poser comme ça vous avez également le
mode tente ça c'est super pratique pour
le côté visionnage de films de séries
j'aime beaucoup de mots tu te permets de
la rse permet de le ventiler et regardez
ce que vous voulez donc on est vraiment
sur un ordinateur
vira pour tout bien évidemment avant
tout ici à usage professionnel mais si
on veut l'utiliser à usage particulier
pour venir faire de la compta faire ce
qu'on veut c'est faux tout les
compagnies ont peu et pour me regarder
des films et des séries très facilement
par votre tante et ça me plaît bien et
en plus ici vous avez une licence chrome
enterprises and white qui inclut
l'accent n'est pas très bon mais la
licence année là dedans donc ça c'est
cool côté performances on va retrouver
ici à l'intérieur un processeur de
qualcomm c'est un qualcomm snapdragon 7
c à 8 heures vous avez 8 gigas de ram et
64 giga de stockage en eux-mêmes c est
comme on est sur un chromebook ici on va
rechercher une grosse autonomie une
grande journée d'utilisation sans
problème et vous le prenez vous l'avez
recharger en usb c'est vous repartez où
vous voulez a servi aux annonces 13,5
heures d'autonomie soit une journée
complète vous avez ici deux micros
intégrés pour vos visions contre un qu'a
situait juste la loi que si tu veux je
te la queue mieux vous avez webcam on a
ici un clavier azerty qui est rétro
éclairé est également un trackpad plus
grand et pratique
ici on a donc deux produits différents
qui s'adresseront à deux types de
personnes avec le spin 513 j'ai un
produit élégant et puissant à la fois
qu'il ira très bien à des commerciaux
tout terrain ce qu'on vient chercher
souvent que des chromebooks et une
grande autonomie si vous l'avez vous
êtes vraiment tranquille on peut donc
imaginer un commercial qui prend la
route et qui pourra utiliser pendant dix
heures soit une journée complète en
absolument aucun problème et l'autre
côté on a le spleen 512 comme ils
démarrent rapidement on est directement
au travail
on a une interface qui est hyper simple
à utiliser il est protégé contre les
logiciels malveillants et bien bloquer
les biens russes
il ya une consommation d'énergie est
très faible et une très bonne autonomie
il sera super bien pour les entreprise
collaborative et pour les salariés qui
travaillent en mobilité
on a donc ici deux produits le
chromebook c'est le spin 513 et on a
également le chromebook le spin 512
l'aurès elle-même l'expérience est là
même l'autonomie est très bonne dans un
cas comme dans l'autre ils ont chacun
leur spécificité personnellement je
trouve ça plutôt intéressant vous de me
dire vous
vous vous derrière la caméra toi
derrière ton écran qu'est ce que tu
penses qu est ce que vous pensez vous de
ces deux ordinateurs acer chromebooks
pin 512 acea chromebooks pin 513 vous le
remarquez bien évidemment en bas en bas
aux commentaires et s'il vous intéresse
oui s'il vous intéresse je vous invite
tous les liens en bas dans la
description aller jeter un oeil à les y
jeter vos yeux et vous verrez les
prisons super intéressant si vous
cherchez une solution business si vous
êtes une entreprise si vous êtes
freelance si vous êtes une tpe si vous
êtes une pme souhaitent une
multinationale
c'est un produit qui est super
intéressant qu'on peut venir utiliser
bien évidemment à usage professionnel
mais aussi à usage particulier hyper
optimisé pour se déplacer et chromebook
c'est une solution que j'aime beaucoup
et se trompent super pertinentes alors
on n'ira pas aussi loin que ce qu'on
fera dès qu'un ordinateur avec beaucoup
de performances mais ici c'est pas
l'idée ici c'est la polyvalence
ici c'est l' os ici c'est le catalogue
c'est le plextor ici c'est la grosse
autonomie et puis surtout une machine
qui se plie de tous les côtés voilà bon
ça j'aime bien j'aime beaucoup donc
marquer ma tout ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire des s'il ya des gros
bisous le monde beaucoup d'amour moi je
vous laisse je bois un coup je mangerai
gâteau sainte barbe bien taillée des
bijoux ou ko mom amour